The Woman in the House
Across the Street
from the Girl in the Window
features a lot of wine,
a lot of broken
casserole dishes,
and a lot of
shocking revelations.
This video
is here to explain
all those twists and turns,
so make sure you've
watched the series first.
There are lots
of spoilers to come.
No!
With that in mind,
time to pour
two massive glasses of red
and get down to business.
Anna sees
a woman being murdered
in the window in the house
across the street -
don't worry,
I won't keep saying that.
The woman is Lisa Maines,
the air hostess girlfriend
of Neil,
who is the handsome dad
who has just moved in
to the house across...
No. The property
opposite Anna's.
Anna is settling in for
her nightly pint of wine,
when she sees
Lisa with her throat cut.
Problem is,
when the police turn up,
there's no blood or body,
and Neil says
Lisa is out of town
in her job
as an air hostess.
What follows is six episodes
of red herrings,
to go with
all that red wine.
Neil's past is littered
with dead women,
which we'll explain
in a second,
but he's also seen
carrying a body in a sack.
Oh my God.
Which turns out to be
a ventriloquist's dummy.
Might actually be
more creepy than a body.
It's my
ventriloquist's dummy.
What?
Then there's Rex,
arrested in episode six,
once the police
find Lisa's body.
Turns out
he was under surveillance
for a different crime
and was recorded
threatening to kill Lisa.
I swear to God, Chastity,
I'm gonna fucking kill you.
I'm gonna cut you
into little pieces
so they can't find--
Again, we can explain
that one in a minute.
The biggest red herring
of them all is Anna herself.
Lisa's body was found
near one of the painter's
palette knives.
And to make matters worse,
she had accidentally
brandished the knife
at Carol
in an earlier episode.
You stop telling people that
-I have a drinking problem.
-Anna!
And was seen having
an argument with Lisa.
You know what?
Let me call you back.
We know it was
about her throwing away
smelly colouring pens,
but to the outside world,
it looked like a threat.
This in turn
unlocks a memory in Anna
of stabbing Lisa
with the palette knife.
And there's blood dripping
down from the attic.
The solution
is a bit more innocent.
Oh my God.
The blood is red paint,
and her memory
comes from slashing
at a painting of Lisa.
As we see early on,
Anna's trauma prevents her
from finishing any painting,
and makes her destroy
her half-finished attempts.
She no more murdered Lisa
than she murdered
these flowers.
I didn't stab her.
I didn't kill anybody.
Okay, maybe
it's a bit sinister
that she was painting
pictures of Lisa
in the first place,
but it's better than
being an actual murderer.
No, the shocking reveal
is that it was
Neil's daughter Emma
who was responsible
all along,
driven to a murderous rage
by Lisa's refusal
to buy her chocolate bars.
Emma?
People always
underestimate children.
Underestimate
what they're capable of.
We can't be
the only ones who got chills
from her transformation,
from young entrepreneur
to violent maniac.
Emma then stole
Anna's palette knife
when she was distracted
getting her chequebook,
and used that to frame her.
And if you're wondering
why Neil
didn't suspect anything?
Well, he missed
the murder itself
because he was
practising ventriloquism
in the bathroom.
But what about
her absence after that?
As Detective Lane
explained earlier,
it would be easy for someone
to take Lisa's phone
and text
fake messages to Neil.
I'm sure
he has a phone somewhere.
Texted himself an alibi,
sent all those texts
to Neil.
Neil also thought
Lisa was flying to Seattle
as an air hostess.
But, as we discover,
she wasn't an air hostess.
The airline in question,
Olympia,
doesn't even fly
to the West Coast.
And because Lisa
was lying about her job,
it made it all the more easy
for Emma to hide her murder.
Of course,
that first question
should maybe be,
"Who killed Chastity?"
Yes, it turns out Lisa
was living a double life,
working with
her partner in crime, Rex,
to scam rich men.
And Neil was
just their next target.
Anna had her suspicions
way back in episode two,
where she discovered
that Lisa was being followed
by a mysterious account
on Instagram
called Sexy Rexy.
Look at this.
Fire emoji, fire emoji.
Eggplant emo--
Eggplant emoji?
Do you know what
an eggplant emoji means?
-Yes.
-It means a dick.
At the time, Anna thought
Lisa was having an affair,
but it's
more complicated than that.
Lisa is actually Chastity,
a bartender
at the strip club
where Rex works as a dancer.
When the two meet,
she draws him into a scheme.
She targets
recently widowed men,
and tricks them into
starting a relationship,
before introducing Rex
as her sick brother
in order to scam
money out of them
for a fake operation.
They're pulling off
the scam with Neil
when Lisa/Chastity
is murdered,
which is why Rex turns up
on Anna's doorstep,
before moving
to Anna's stairs,
shower and kitchen worktop.
One reason
Anna is suspicious of Neil
is because when
she looks into his past,
she finds a trail of bodies.
-Oh my God.
-Well, two bodies.
I think
that counts as a trail.
There's Neil's wife,
Meredith,
allegedly
drowned in the lake,
and Maxine, Emma's teacher,
who fell off a cliff
during a school trip
chaperoned by Neil.
Neil was
the only adult present
at both crime scenes,
which leads to Anna
picturing him as the killer.
Of course, the only
other person at both scenes
was Emma herself,
and as we now know,
this kid is not as sweet as
the chocolate she's selling.
Jealous of
the second child on the way,
she killed her pregnant mum
by sabotaging the lake pier.
She also pushed her teacher
from the lighthouse
for reasons unknown.
There's a surprising amount
of upper body strength
in that tiny kid.
Throughout
The Woman in the House,
Anna is convinced
there's something bad
happening in the attic.
Hello?
She hears creaks,
and we see a shadowy figure
at the end
of the first episode.
Again, it's all
a harmless misunderstanding.
Well, as harmless
as having a handyman
secretly living
in your loft can be.
Buell has been
living up here.
Yes, turns out that
friendly Buell has been
sleeping in the rafters.
It's easy to suspect
the DIY expert
of being up to no good.
Not only has he spent
several years
fixing that mailbox,
but he's played
by Cameron Britton,
forever associated
in our heads
as the terrifying Ed Kemper
in Netflix serial-killer
drama Mindhunter.
Thankfully,
his only crime here
is being a very slow worker,
and maybe some
inappropriate taxidermy.
The show ends
with a final twist
as Anna flies out
to New York one year later.
-Red or white?
-Oh.
No, thank you.
I don't drink wine anymore.
I'll have a vodka.
She sits next to
a mysterious businesswoman,
played by
film legend Glenn Close,
and accidentally
drinks herself into a stupor
by mixing vodka
with a Xanax prescription.
She wakes up,
finds Glenn Close's body
in the toilets,
only for the body to vanish
when she alerts the crew.
Yes, it's almost
the same setup as the murder
that kicked the show off.
Let's get you
back to your seat.
Though this time, not only
has the body gone missing,
but the crew claim
there wasn't
a passenger in the seat
to begin with.
There was no one in seat 2A.
Just as the police thought
Anna was imagining
Lisa's murder,
based on the book
she was reading at the time,
The Woman Across the Lake,
Anna is now reading
the sequel,
The Girl on the Cruise.
If you look carefully
at the blurb on the back,
it's the same story as hers.
Having survived one mystery,
the heroine takes a trip,
only for a lady to vanish
from the boat she's on.
Is this
Anna's mind playing tricks,
or a setup for a sequel?
One thing is for sure:
after eight episodes
of pitch-perfect parody,
we'd devour some more.
Bingo.
And so we reach the end of -
deep breath -
The Woman in the House
Across the Street
from the Girl in the Window.
Who knew a comedy
could keep us this gripped?
If you're looking to see
how accurate the parody is,
you could check out
The Woman in the Window
on Netflix.
And if you enjoyed
this breakdown,
subscribe
to Still Watching Netflix
for more videos like it.